this morning president elect Donald
Trump officially named his pick to lead
the US Environmental Protection Agency
Oklahoma Attorney General Scott Pruett
the swearing-in ceremony took place in
the White House treaty room with Supreme
Court Justice Samuel Alito administering
the oath Trump's EPA Chief came into
office determined to end what he dubbed
the agency's anti-energy agenda by
loosening requirements on carbon
emissions and eliminating land use
restrictions Pruett has set out to
transform the agency he leads perhaps to
a greater extent than any of Trump's
other cabinet appointees we as an agency
and we as a nation could be both pro
energy and jobs and pro-environment
one of his biggest targets a
controversial rule on water pollution
put in place by the Obama administration
you had a power grab that was taking
place the EPA when they were trying to
assert jurisdiction over land use
decisions that were being made by
private property owners in cities and
towns and states across the country
progressives were outraged he is going
to dismantle everything in place the air
you breathe the water you drink to
understand why property rights advocates
applauded Pruitt's move consider the
case of fourth-generation farmer John
Duarte who's fought a protracted and
costly legal battle with federal
regulators over how to tell his 450 acre
farm in Tehama County California if the
government can do this to us there's no
family in America who can farm their
land without concern the government can
come onto their property and take
everything they own my family's farming
history goes back to my
great-grandfather's we produce
grapevines almond trees pistachio trees
walnuts avocados and a few other minor
crops the government is saying that our
tillage of this ground to plant a wheat
crop violated the Clean Water Act in
2012 the Army Corps of Engineers working
in conjunction with the EPA accused
Wardy of damaging wetland features on
his property the penalty over 30 million
in fines and restoration fees but
getting permission before plowing wasn't
really an option the average time
to obtain Clean Water Act permit is
close to two years and the average cost
just to hire the consultants and do the
studies to get permits approaches a
quarter of a million dollars attorney
Anthony Francois with the Pacific Legal
Foundation represented warty in his case
against the government clearly if you
had to undertake that kind of cost and
time just to get the necessary permit to
plow your fields every year you're not
gonna grow a lot of food
awardees trouble stemmed from a
provision in the Clean Water Act known
as the waters of the United States rule
that was meant to better protect large
bodies of water by regulating use of the
streams ponds and ditches that flow into
them but in a power grab by agency
bureaucrats Obama's EPA expanded the
power granted by this provision using it
as licensed to micromanage private land
use to the point of absurdity the agency
accused Wardy of mismanaging the wetland
areas located on his property claiming
that his 4-inch plow furrows created
small mountain ranges not those
mountains these ones that's what we have
right here these between these furrows
they're saying that the bottom of this
furrow is still a wetland but the top of
this 405 inches higher is a converted
upland attorney-general's from 31 states
including Pruitt challenged the Obama
administration's overreached on the
Clean Water Act the broad trend of
environmental regulation during the
Obama administration was to use the
coercive threat or reality of regulation
simply to try to shut down entire
industries and entire types of economic
activity that's university of virginia
law professor Jason Scott Johnston he
says that the Obama administration
expanded the definition of wetlands
beyond the parameters set by the Supreme
Court in a 2007 decision they have
promulgated the definition of wetlands
which clearly contradicts what the
Supreme Court said they're gonna go out
and regulate things that they consider
to be wetlands even though this Court
has said they're not EPA so-called
waters of the United States rule is one
of the worst examples of federal
regulation and it has truly run amok
Trump administration has started the
process of repealing the rule but faces
multiple legal hurdles and getting it
off the books could take several years
faced with millions of dollars in fines
duarte settled his case in August for
1.1 million
he hopes Pruitt's focus on regulatory
rollback will restore the property
rights of farmers we become peasants
where these federal prosecutors can come
in like the Sheriff of Nottingham decide
for themselves well they think a family
can pay decide for themselves if they
want to destroy a family and take their
land away if the federal prosecutors can
come on this farm with this set of facts
there is no farm in America that is safe
from this kind of prosecution
[Music]